hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to deep asleep the sequel to
deep sleep and if it's no mystery I just
got off playing the first one and it was
actually really really awesome I am
playing with headphones the lights are
down I'm ready to get the band scared
off and we can play an interesting story
I've always wanted to experience a lucid
dream a dream in which you are awake a
dream in which you could be anyone and
do anything so why did I dream that
nightmare up but something went wrong
and I ended up having a terrible
nightmare okay I should just shut up
before I woke up I encountered monsters
that wanted to hurt me I did not a
counter on there I don't think they were
a part of my dream it felt like they
came from outside from the depths the
nightmare didn't fade away like I
thought it would I couldn't stop
thinking about it
what if it was real I became obsessed
with it I don't know why maybe I just
wanted to prove myself wrong so I went
to a local library to see if there were
any past records of dreams similar to
mine oh okay I'm literally here this is
exactly where I am okay more books about
the human psyche on Anana
nothing about loopy okay so nothing
interesting here for me so I expect
there's gonna be a lot of various
clickety clicking and at some point I'm
about to fall asleep I know that as much
now what I'm looking for okay nothing
interesting here nothing here nothing
here nothing here nothing here nothing
here oh boy who's gonna be fun clicking
on all of these little details nothing
there all right moving on anybody a
piece of paper as long as you don't know
who you are
Oh as long as you don't know you're
dreaming you are safe
Oh dreaming right now oh why
how could you oh boy they had it good
wine come on stop doing the Mambo and
let me look at it here
okay so there's nothing on the ground I
need nothing here I need okay let's go
over here
oh boy book a dusty old book ah am I
supposed to put this back what oh okay I
get it
so it's a whole reality gonna start
tearing yourself apart over here ah
there's a book missing there let me just
put that right back in place
perfect that's the door I came into the
library from and here we go
batteries right off the bat hey step
painting of the horse unicorn oh he's a
paper have existed since human race well
okay then that's interesting hello hi
it's locked
good we want to go through there oh good
an elevator no power even better okay hi
hi what are you okay bike hi again I'm
back
did you miss me it's too dark to see
anything I see you something maybe
you're too much of a [ __ ] to see but it
looks like that's it tricking it it's
gonna be when I turn the lights on it's
not really gonna be eyes is it it's
scared for no reason
fine Oh
Oh ding-ding would like to not be in
this nightmare please oh that's
different
oh oh this very different God what is
with the creep what is with the
creepiness piece of paper ghoul I first
encountered this the early 80s but have
existed since human race okay fine
oh it's even better now that I know that
I just saw you there's a code silhouette
no dirt no dirt you key then hahaha I'm
not going anywhere near you until I
absolutely need to fly from the other
side so this key definitely would not
work okay that would just be illogical
in this dream of mine that door no Bronk
eat ah there's another key I can't reach
it
really jump gosh jump you wimp oh okay
handles still stuck on that son of a
[ __ ]
hi Burt how are you can i honk your nose
can I punch you in the face
wrong you it's locked how about that one
that won't do it
I lit the other one tough still won't
work bye Burt have a good day okay
Jean lost police turning us off very
lost there any other way that it could
have gone but what about this one
ah I'm a winner is anybody's leaving a
tear I yell extremely loudly ended as
I'm sleeping ha ha okay this is calmly
go Danny where's Cody
Tobey Tommy Willy Cody Cody Cody Cody he
needs his bear by the lion tiger thing I
don't have it okay Cody it's really
quiet here no no there was a point of me
going in there hand let me see if
there's something else around here that
I need
I'm gonna go hi
okay hello oh yes somehow it's even
worse okay why was it glowing
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha he's paper lucid
dreaming thank you for that pertinent
information that was very very helpful
[ __ ] ah seven four four six okay
fine son of a [ __ ]
do that to me again I got a pointer
point yeah world when you're right out
of existence I'll probably do nothing
okay piece of paper um I don't know if
I'm gonna find all of them which
sometimes happens during comas okay
I swear I'm hearing noises you know it's
a good horror game when it makes me
paranoid enough to check around me for
noises hello you lovely you don't have
any commentary on that lovely thing
great least I got a code now I can go
into a bit less [ __ ] all right so now
I got the code I can do this thing seven
four four six batos key get it open as
if I really want to I know what's gonna
happen oh I did this exact thing hello
hi boy wouldn't it be lovely if there
was no power by possessing bodies that's
a good sign that's a good sign
that's a good sign right there okay here
we go again oh the doors open huh so I
need to go even deeper is this the point
where I'm going deeper
that's nike's okay okay all right here
we go hi how're those eyeballs old toys
umbrella
what the hell ah didn't quite catch that
could you say it last night merrily
hello what the hell is that a needle
what kind of needle katya injecting your
arm oh okay I first encountered this
phenomena in the early eighties but it
would seem they have existed since the
dawn of the human race
very interesting why the human race
specifically why not the animal races
all right I'm leaving now boys sure hope
nothing chases me you dick with me
ancient it's not gonna be the same thing
but it's gonna be similar in it okay
closing I don't the doors already open
but I want to cause it shut up it's my
TV over there keeps turning off okay
everything's fine everything is awesome
everything is cool when you're part of a
team
ding-dong okay what do I do with this so
I would put the needle in the tire put
the pointer in the doodad the doogie in
the buzzer gotta reach that with the
pointer maybe yeah gotta go back down I
know where that was oh no anything else
and volunteering the Papa wool then shut
the F up
okay I'm out I'm Audi I'm out of here
all right cool that's cool no but also
screw you hi Burton there we go
well I got that open so what was the
point I gotta get Cody is damn needle
Tiger back what did I just do okay
okay pile of stones where's my lucky
piece of coal those are some attractive
looking trees on that way not in the
five nights and Freddie's way I've seen
some things
hello piece of paper I thought there was
something there I don't know if I'm
gonna find all of them they attack
detached from okay there's no point in
even reading this until it's all
assembled it's not gonna make much sense
oh hello oh hello oh I see
so I need to find a way to get the water
flowing finding pieces of paper in the
woods this feels familiar so uh what am
i oh oh oh oh as long as you don't know
where you're dreaming you're safe they
attack when you see they sense a mind to
tan from its bodies which sometimes
happen during comas or me am I in a coma
okay no one looking for so it's not
gonna let me guess my way through the
code if that is even a code yeah I'm
headed back time to go into that shed
okay hi oh good I got a bag with a hole
in it just oh hi
I see so I need to fill the bag with the
stones to weigh it down to make five
kilograms that's what you're saying
ain't it
I'm smart intelligent I'm gonna get lost
in these woods there's multiple paths
that's a piece of paper give me that oh
I'm gonna be so lost small man to the
ground
shovel or something keys this game is
much more involved oh that's on the
thumbnail of the thing he's gotta move
oh hi there was a key in the pod well
good for me there's always a key in the
pod what is down there what is it to go
deep how deep deepest is it the deepest
sleep Zep foreshadowing to where I'm
gonna go next screw you screw you
okay I got a key that's all I need right
so laughed pile of rocks so I use the
bag on the pile rocks I'll bag is a hole
in it I need to find out needle with
okay I need to needle the thread and get
the okay I got it
I get it I get it I get it I get what
was that wait it wasn't there good yeah
I know no Ezra okay bye okay bye bye bye
bye hi Bert hi okay gotta get the power
going
the first Cody needs his
okay bye I'm gonna go find where this
key goes ooh
unlock the door good wrench that's
useful for bashing in the heads of
things I found another piece of paper I
know I've missed some they live but
desperately that sounds like me right
now ding ding ding ding ding do I gotta
go outside again I have anything else
that could help me I got a need to find
some like thread or something he's got
me some pipe wrench for the thing oh my
god nothing happens the valve is already
opened with nothing happened
yay what does that do
hey I'm gonna bash this door down I got
a pointer okay what else is going on
down here
huh did that Susan did that do something
down there all right you [ __ ] see what
you got come on what you guy
come on bring it on I'm ready we got aah
I know what I need to do uh-huh nothing
happens what I mean nothing happens well
come on
so I open those valves what does that do
dude there must be another valve
somewhere there must be another valve
somewhere I'm gonna go back outside hi
Bert I'm bashing in the face Bert how
about I put a needle through your face
I'll point you in the face gotta be
something else out here okay what is
that okay there's something down here I
didn't go down this path this is
different than the other ones find
another piece of paper okay night folk
are in the realm of dreams
okay good message then nice talk we had
there hey is that a scary crow okay hey
you look comforting I really like this
tall grass that we got going on here
whoo hello thread yes yes empty bag
perfect I didn't even need the old
sewing machine okay I got it
I knew there had to be thread somewhere
around here so now I can get this put
the stones in the bag
go to the thing put it on the thing get
out of the thing go wake up and then
have a fun time at chuck-e-cheeses a
Freddy fazbear bird well the back is 1/3
full what I mean what stones weren't
good enough really
I need dirt from that mound whatever
loser
me pal there we go I put ground in the
bag literally the whole ground I put it
in the bags just to make five kilograms
okay there we go what awaits me oh good
the last one real high Opie's 11 a
better than the last one I hear water
flowing in the pipes that means that
there's electricity now should be the
fountain do daddy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yes okay it's a puzzle I'm bad
at these done gotta gotta gotta got it
okay so that's filling up that's good
I'm standing in water at least it's
working now whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh
saw something okay nevermind I did not I
did not saw something alright but we
have success that means that we have
power that means it something probably
not gonna be too happy about man ever
these woods get creepier every time I
walk through them okay but either way hi
Burt oh I like what you've done with
your eyeballs okay but either way I have
power now but what the hell happened is
Cody still could be still creepy okay
but either way there's power so that I
mean that I can
I couldn't have been more ominous I'm an
imam - leave me negative one doesn't
stop the ground floor
what floor am I on okay oh good
what the hell what the hell what the
hell okay this looks like the toy room
okay hi what's up [ __ ] are you okay no
no no no no no no no no oh where do I go
where do I go I'm Jack okay without my
screws ah oh god what el okay okay
that's bad
come on my god Jesus
it is the lady from the ring no I don't
want to do any horror movies good lordy
it's terrifying
okay do you lay I have a screwdriver now
so that's cool let's go to negative one
I wonder what good could come out of
that so I got a screwdriver that's cool
the first time I've had a chance to die
in this whole game Oh
I mean maybe okay I got it okay so now
that I have the rope does that mean that
I can
I got a thing for all hi a poster a
generic no name non burnt poster key I'm
assuming this rope needs to go on the
well I would just assume that's all I
can assume all righty then oh god it's
totally the ring it's so the ring oh
it's so the ring oh it's othering there
will be no going back oh so the ring
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay hi oh you can't do that to me even
though you can in there I know there's
another game out already
Oh huh a young boy wakes up from a
3-month coma a nine year old boy from a
local orphanage who has been in a coma
since February woke up yesterday in good
health doctors previously didn't give
him much of a chance of ever regaining
consciousness boy's first words after
opening his eyes were my Tigers found me
I did it I get it
I didn't even know I did it I didn't
even know if that worked Cody you're
welcome see you're the fall no I missed
a note ah I miss a note god wow I was
that close it was probably when I was
panicking of the lady there was probably
a note there that I missed sorry about
that I really do apologize but hey maybe
someone else did better than I did I was
in a bit of hurry if you don't mind my
saying but either way this is awesome
can't wait to play the last and possibly
final one but anyway thank you all so
much for watching check out the other
scary games I've done in the playlist
over there in the description below and
as always I will see you in the next
video good one